Pete Davidson has been spotted out and
about getting cozy with Chase Suey
wonders now a source tells E.T the two
like each other a lot oh what is she
doing here
Pete and Chase co-starred in the 2022
flick bodies bodies bodies where's Maxie
not responding my text s
and on Monday they were snapped with
their bodies bodies bodies all cozied up
to one another TMZ reports that they
were spotted getting cuddly at a
restaurant in Brooklyn sitting on the
same side of the table according to the
outlet Chase put her arm around Pete as
they waited for their food and when it
came they took it to go leaving in the
same car I feel very lucky and according
to an ET Source the two have been
spending a lot of time together quote
they're both funny so they laugh a lot
together and their connection is natural
Pete likes that chase is down to earth
and cool romance rumors first sparked
last month when the pair was spotted at
a New York Rangers game at Madison
Square Garden with their other bodies
bodies bodies co-star Rachel Senate
that's Pete rocking a black leather
jacket Brown hoodie and cap Chase opting
for a black oversized letterman jacket
yeah we're keeping it clean
of course this possible new relationship
comes after Pete was most recently
linked to Emily radakowski he's got the
height he is obviously women find him
very attractive he seems super Charming
he's vulnerable he's lovely great his
fingernail polish is awesome like he
looks good there you go great all right
well I'm sold I'm gonna have him back on
good relationship with his mother yeah
great relationship with his mother we
love it a source confirmed to E.T that
the two were dating in November
explaining they've known each other for
a while because they run in similar
circles quote they've always had a good
time together and liked each other and
shortly after that Emily and Pete took
their relationship courtside at a New
York Knicks Memphis Grizzlies game also
at Madison Square Garden I've been
fortunate enough to have some great
relationships and you know uh honesty is
always really important in December A
source told ET that Emily thinks Pete is
hysterical and he thinks she's smoking
hot but they they weren't putting any
pressure on the relationship not too
long after that ET Source confirmed that
things had fizzled out between them and
while she didn't name names Emily got
real about the challenges of dating
earlier this month on her podcast Hi-Lo
I feel like a lot of men who truly think
they want a strong woman actually don't
know how to handle it and they don't
know what it means for their own
identity I've said to my girlfriend I'm
like I feel like I attract the worst
much because I want an a confident man I
don't want an overly confident man who
has something to prove and is trying to
prove it through me so Emily and Pete
didn't work out and we'll just have to
wait and see if Pete and chase keep
their bodies bodies bodies together but
safe to say Pete knows how to keep us
guessing
foreign